هيه
يا سعودي
[تصفيق]
اتوقع اثنين صفر للسعوديه كلنا حماس اكيد
اثنين صفر للسعوديه صدق اليوم عيد ميلادك
ولا
ابعد بلادي ايه ايه 30 كان ب30 يلا
الامر الطويل
حياتي كلها ان شاء الله
وان شاء الله
نقول اثنين واحد ان شاء الله السعوديه ان
شاء الله شو اول شيء حتسويه بس تفوزوا
بنسوي مسيرات اكيد
فرحه فرحه وطن كامل ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
ثانكيو
شباب شو توقعاتكم لمباراه اليوم
من الدنمارك بالترتيب الاول ان شاء الله
فرنسا واستراليا
ضد السعوديه
المنتخب السعودي ان شاء الله
كاس العالم
بولندا لكن
مستوى جميل جدا مع المنتخب البولندي لكن
قدر الله وما شاء فعل لابس 16 فهد المولد
صح ولا سالم الدوسري سالم الدوسري 19
في التدريب ان شاء الله كم النتيجه اليوم
2 1 للسعوديه ان شاء الله عشان تكون
مباراه حلوه منتخب يسوونها ان شاء الله
وهم رجال زي ما سواها قدام الارجنتين يقدر
يسوون قدام اي فريق ثاني باذن الله انتصار
سعودي ثقه عاليه اليوم الثقه الثقه عاليه
لان في نجوم في الملعب في ناس تلعب وتناس
تتعب وقاعدين يقدمون اكثر مجهود وشفناهم
بولندا كيف قدموا مستوى لكن الحظ ما حلفنا
وباذن الله ان شاء الله نفوز اليوم اليوم
طلعتوا في المركز الثاني هتلعب مع فرنسا
بالدور الجاي
فرنسا السعودي